what are the other pieces of this that
we're seeing other companies to do
Twitter for example now is doing this
thing like if you're gonna send some you
know crazy tweet that they detect you
whether it's through language or kind of
intention they will basically put an
interstitial that says hey like hey are
you sure you want to send this like you
know basically be nice to people and it
you can click through and send it but it
just makes people stop and think for a
second I almost wonder of Apple to get
to the place where isn't have to like
proactively tell me what to put on my
calendar but if it knows that I'm about
to schedule the you know ninth meeting
for the day and there's no work out
planned on the calendar it says like are
you sure you want to schedule this on
days where you don't work out and you
have you know more than X number of
hours for meetings then you feel like
[ __ ] and don't sleep well you know maybe
you want to switch this meeting out for
a workout like that again it's somewhat
predictive but also somewhat like the
experience these are Americans that
feels like that is a inflection point on
the individuals life they may not create
you know buildings and alter market camp
for Apple in the short term but it just
feels like that would change my
relationship with Apple and further
deepen it because I just can't get that
anywhere else
yeah in it this this is goes into like
another broader thing that I've been
I've been thinking about but like when
you start going into these software
things like should you work or should
you relax
should you see your family should you go
to sleep should you work out there is
like the health component of that but
there's also like a value system
component of like what should Apple be
telling you to do what should Twitter be
telling you to say and I think this is
where you get into the this is partially
where my thinking had gone after the
Apple stuff but like what gets what
happens when you start having these
companies that look like countries in
terms of your choosing to be a part of
them for your lifetime and and how are
if you're opting into their value system
and Apple chooses to prefer that you
should be spending more time with family
than then working that's a value system
choice more than than anything else and
I think we start ending up in a really
really interesting in weird place I
forget who wrote the piece but someone
came out with something there was an
important policy review about about it
was really focused on zoom but the idea
that when you have companies that
operate internationally and across
especially like China in the u.s. there
essentially one company that has to deal
with to value systems and that
expression in the to value systems is
oftentimes in massive conflict I don't
know where it goes but like apples going
to have to if they're gonna play this
game they're gonna have to choose and
codify their value system they're
essentially gonna have to have a
constitution for what it means to be a
citizen of Apple is the citizen at Apple
someone who only maximizes GDP are they
purely like a Protestant type person is
it someone that is purely focused like a
Sweden on unhappiness or something like
that those are these are like these are
more value choices and that's where you
say like oh my gosh like these companies
like like I guess we'll stick with Apple
but like Apple I think did 260 billion
dollars in revenue I'm I'm pretty sure
if you look at like the OECD countries
the only ones like above I think Sweden
is just on the barrier honestly I'd like
they did two hundred sixty billion
dollars in tax revenue last year and
like that that is the scale at which
Apple is operating and so you're just
starting to like blur the line of what
is possible what goods should they be
providing what value should they be
pushing and which of these are you're
gonna op into as an individual because
it really is a lifetime decision what is
your biggest what seems like the least
obvious thing that Apple will do but you
believe they will in the next ten years
but like what's that one thing we're
like people aren't thinking about this
enough but you think it's a foregone
conclusion um I think I think it's a
foregone conclusion ma'am I I guess like
I mean it's honestly about the whole
thing I think it's a foregone conclusion
that your primary care provider will be
Apple at some point in the future I
think like priek Ovid there was a big
narrative that I think people have
forgotten about where Apple was moving
their stores from stores to town squares
like they were literally calling that
like if this isn't this is like apples
colonialism of like the US like every
city is gonna have like an apple town
square and if you're telling me what do
you put in a town square you have a
store for buying the things you also
have a place for getting the health
things and you have a place for
educating yourself like this was their
whole narrative I think a year ago and
they're like big announcements was like
we are manifesting Google in the
physical world beyond just a
transactional place we're a place where
you get educated
we're a place where you get the things
you need and if I think about the stuff
that government provides and assists
like that or a country it's it's it's
it's education health care and then
protection and I think they are clearly
doing education and providing the
products I think health care is next and
the question is like do they actually
get into the the game of violence like
do you protect these values that you
created that's the ultimate government
move